Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter, Author,
Director, Producer: I don't want life
to beat me. I've seen life beat so
many people (most people) around me,
life beat them. When you ask them what
happened, what do most people say?
Life happened man. I had it there and this
happened in that. I don't want life to beat me.
Film Courage: We republished this tweet
from The Numbers Game on our channel page
and it says “Squid Game creator wrote the show
in 2009 but was rejected by studios for 10 years.
He once had to stop writing the script and sell
his $675.00 dollar laptop due to money troubles
and today Squid Game is number one I guess
in 90 countries and is set to become the most
watched show in Netflix history.” What is your
reaction to this the story, this chain of events?
Joston: I mean if it's true, it's awesome. It’s
that feeling of the never say die attitude no
matter how much rejection you get you still keep
plowing forward and I love those stories I do
um I think that I always if the story is
is completely third party then I feel that
it's it's an awesome story of perseverance but
if it's a a Netflix story which I I'm a Netflix
subscriber I definitely watch it but they can
tell you what's number one and you just have to
believe that it's true we have no
way of verifying that it's number one
only that they said it was number one I always
wonder that whenever I'm looking at the the like
this is number one for the week and number ten
for the week I'm like how do we really know that
that's number one and number ten it's just because
we went there and they told us that it was so
um but like I said before if it's the story if the
story is true and it's you know it's a third party
story that's a great story of perseverance um I
think that we people are born with a lot of quit
in them for some reason or maybe it's
developed over the years but when they
start to reach those obstacles or any kind of
adversity it's it's very easy to to give up and
unfortunately I think that we all have
people in our lives who care about us
greatly they care about us deeply and they will
see us going through some adversity and it's like
oh man it's been years you probably should maybe
maybe you should start thinking about something
else because they care about you and they want
you to be successful and they don't want to see
you kind of beating your head against the wall
and they'll sometimes advise you to maybe maybe
throw in a towel on this one and I'm pretty sure
he had that person next to him telling him that
and when I always hear about people who have those
advisors with them I always say find new advisors
because the only thing that people should help you
understand is why you care so deeply about what
you're doing that's always the real question why
do you care so deeply and after that they should
just be trying to help you achieve whatever the
goal is you're trying to achieve or give you the
best advice they could on how to achieve
it you know I know you said you left your
uh job as a marketing coordinator at a nursing
skilled nursing facility but have you ever been
tempted to give up on films as many rollercoaster
rides as you've been on it sounds like
no no I 've I've had times where it was tough
and ultimately you had to feed the safe you
know you have to say okay you know I gotta focus
on putting money over here and this and that but
I've I they always say that the the line
between uh self-belief and delusion is very thin
and I must be riding that line because I've just
I've always believed especially after I left the
skilled nursing facility that it's this robust is
this robust and I'm very very fortunate that I've
gotten to a point where now I self-finance all
of my projects and you know I think that I can
service two different demographics I can service
the horror crowd which is what most people know my
work uh from is horror and in that like 80s style
horror and then I can also serve a niche of people
who are like me who like the kind of stuff that
I like and that's a smaller niche but I can still
serve that niche and that's where I get to really
be the most creative that I could possibly be
but that took time to get to that point and it
took a lot of sacrifice to get to that point
and I think there are moments in
everybody's life where they realize that
man this is very difficult and I wonder if
the juice is worth the squeeze at this point
but it is my belief that once you start to feel
that that's when you should be your most um
decisive in going forward
and the reason is because
success and everything you're looking for is just
on the other side of that it's it's when you don't
have the teeth to keep going and you give up
you you cut yourself short and you always wonder
what if I just kept going what if I had just given
it another this or made that one extra phone call
but I never want those questions and what I
found is right when you have when you get past
that point everything I was looking for was just
on the other side it was just on the other side
and I'm starting to reap a lot of the benefits of
that perseverance and continuously going forward
would you say that's one of your biggest
fears is the fear of regret you don't ever
want to get to a certain point and go I
wish I had just done this tried harder um
no I think more than anything I just I don't
want to feel like and it's going to sound really
weird but I don't want to feel like life beat me
I don't want life to beat me I've seen life beat
so many people most people around me life beat
them when you ask them what happened what do most
people say life happened man I had it there and
this happened in that I don't want life to beat
me I take everything that comes with life and I
try to use it to my benefit everything you know
at this point my wife is is is pregnant right
guess who's gonna be in my movie is it my kid
he's gonna be the star of the movie you take
everything that's coming to you and you use it
whatever happens in my life I use it if it's if
it's something crazy and wild happen it's a story
in the script if this happened in that it's in the
script I'm taking everything that comes it comes
towards me and I'm using it I'm using it as fuel
I'm using it as something to keep moving forward
life won't beat me it won't we're hoping to
get your reaction to this comment and that is
this is not a triumph it's a tragedy and it's a
sign of just how much the industry needs to do
better because creative original work should
not be just a long struggle to put it out
referring to the Squid Game and
what are your thoughts on that
um
he didn't let life beat him no he didn't let
life beat him but to say it's not a triumph it's
a tragedy it's like wow really I don't I look you
everything that we do especially in this industry
everything you're trying to do is met with
resistance and opposition it just is it is if
the way I try to explain it to certain people when
they say oh it's nepotism and this person and that
and this is why I can't get in and okay let's say
you are trying to to get through the door okay
in every film I've worked with let's say
we take the collective of everybody I've
worked with in that film maybe seven percent
of them are people I actually work with again
maybe okay and it all has to do with the way
I run my set and what I expect from people
in the end not everybody is gonna operate at
that same level okay and while I can be very
chill I can also be pretty intense you know now
because I'm very passionate about what I'm doing
so if that's the case after a certain amount of
time I'm hopeful that the percentage of people
that I'm working with is growing so that now
I'm carrying over most people from one project
to the next why am I doing that because these
are the people that I know these are the people
that I trust okay and I want to keep them next
to me and I want to keep them working with me
so when the next person comes along and they say
well guess what I can do this and I can do that
I say you probably could and you're probably
great at it but then I would have to take a chance
and maybe on this project I'm already taking
these chances I can't afford to take that chance
and that person can see that as an obstacle to
their growth into their success because they
couldn't get that position on that film they
couldn't get that thing out there and if they
go to more and more people like me who begin
to accumulate a nice team that they work with
a very a team that makes everything work smoothly
they're going to meet that same opposition right
and it will become a game
in terms of trying to find
that crack to squeeze in to get whatever it
is that you're trying to to get made made
so when people speak of the struggle to get things
done that's really the struggle the struggle is
first of all he's written something right and
he has to get it in front of someone to read it
well guess what there's hundreds and thousands
of other scripts that are trying to be read
everybody's trying to get their stuff made the key
is going to be the perseverance and to keep going
and that to me is the triumph of the story as
I said if it's if it's the true story and it's
you know a third party and they're talking about
it to me that is a triumph that's not a tragedy
it's a triumph you took something that is not a
very um it's not a cheap story to make like he
can't go out and get a a camera phone and
shoot that like it doesn't work the same
he's going to need a serious budget guess what
that's even more competitive because to get people
to spend the millions of dollars it's going to
take to make that and market that that's tough
it's very competitive and it shouldn't be easy
because if it were easy it wouldn't be worth it
so excuse me sorry um I disagree with that it's
it's not a it's not a tragedy it's a triumph
what was behind door number one what we didn't
tell you what was missing from that tweet um is
that director huang did not stop during those 10
years he kept working and he wrote and directed I
guess three projects during that time and a lot
of people um they may have just been stuck on
that first one and and trying to make that one
happen so he for whatever reason kept going and
made other work and I don't know the exact story
of how it happened but um it sounds like he wasn't
going to let life beat him down either so yeah
it's a story of perseverance like I said he he
may feel that it was a tragedy he may because
you know two people looking at the same event
can see two totally different things right to me
that's not a that's not a tragedy to me that's a
triumph and hearing that he made other projects
while he was trying to get that one made even
further you know uh solidifies that it's it's
perseverance at its best and it's never giving up
and his plan a I don't think was just to make
Squid Game his plan a was to to be successful
and get something made and that's exactly what
he was getting done Squid Game just took a little
bit longer than the others but ultimately
he got that one done as well when you were
on your way out from the nursing home did
people try to talk you out of leaving yes yeah
but I always make sure that I seek first
to understand and then to be understood and
i could understand why they didn't want me to go
because you know I was a salesman and I was pretty
you know decent at what I did
so they didn't want me to leave
because then that meant that they would have to
find another salesperson and then they'd have to
take a gamble you know and see if that person will
work out and and when it comes to the healthcare
industry especially when it's end of life and it's
it's uh you know assistant living facilities at
skilled nursing facilities home health and hospice
is super competitive it's super competitive so you
need very aggressive sales people and that was
ultimately why they didn't want me to go I mean
I think there were a couple people who just like
talking to me every day and those people didn't
want me to go and I think a few of the patients
but I think or residents I should say but um
for the most part it was it was because of my
skills that they didn't want me to leave and
once I understood that I said that's even more of
a reason to to to kind of leave and not feel too
bad about it you know well they try to talk Jeff
Bezos out of making Amazon so well there you go.
Is Hwang
Dong-hyuk's story a triumph or a tragedy?